Hallo Leute. Heute schauen wir uns die 10
häufigsten Mathefehler an, die viele Schüler
machen und dadurch schlechtere Noten bekommen.
Fehler Nummer 1:
Wenn das hier berechnet werden soll, schreiben
viele einfach a²+b² was allerdings falsch
ist, denn das erkennt ihr sofort, wenn ihr
für a und b eine Zahl einsetzt. Nehmen wir
1 und 2. Und jetzt 1+2 sind 3. 3² sind 9.
Und hier drüben: 1² ist 1 plus 2² ist 4,
also kommt hier 5 raus. Und 5 ist ungleich
9. Das heißt das hier ist nicht das gleiche
wie das hier. Wie können wir das also besser
machen? Stellt euch a+b als eine Strecke vor,
und die soll mit sich selbst multipliziert
werden, denn (a+b)² bedeutet ja nichts weiter
als (a+b)*(a+b). So, wir sollen also eine
Strecke a+b mit sich selbst multiplizieren.
Das heißt geometrisch wir erstellen ein Quadrat.
Wenn wir jetzt hier die Flächen einzeichnen,
erkennen wir schnell: Wir haben hier ein a²
hier ein b², also die beiden. Aber es kommen
noch a*b+a*b hinzu, also 2*a*b. Also +2ab.
Und dann ist das hier auch gleich. Das also
bitte ab sofort merken: (a+b)² ist a²+b²+2ab.
Und richtig, das ist die erste binomische
Formel. Gut.
Fehler Nummer 2:
Wenn diese beiden Brüche miteinander addiert
werden sollen, rechnen manche 1+3 oben und
2+4 unten und erhalten 4/6, was jedoch falsch
ist! Stattdessen müssen wir den gleichen
Nenner herstellen, indem wir den Bruch mit
2 erweitern. Also 2/4+3/4 und wir erhalten
5/4. Und das könnt ihr euch als Kreisflächen
vorstellen. ½ ist ein halber Kreis. ¾ ist
ein Dreiviertelkreis. Und wenn ihr die beiden
zusammenaddiert, können nicht 4/6 herauskommen,
denn 4/6 sind weniger als ein Kreis. Korrekt
wäre hingegen 5/4. Gut, ein weiterer Fehler
bei den Brüchen ist die Multiplikation, wenn
ihr eine ganze Zahl mit einem Bruch multiplizieren
sollt. Manche rechnen dann 3*7 unten und da
kommt 21 raus, also 2/21. Doch das ist definitiv
falsch, denn wir müssen die 3 oben mit der
2 multiplizieren. 3*2 sind 6, also hier kommt
6/7 heraus. Warum ist das so? Überlegen wir
nochmal. 3 kann man ja schreiben als 3/1.
Und die Bruchrechenregel besagt: Zähler mal
Zähler und Nenner mal Nenner. Also 3*2 sind
6. 1*7 sind 7. Gut.
Fehler Nummer 3:
Wenn wir (3+x)/x haben, dann kürzen ja einige
x und x. Und da soll dann 3 rauskommen. Das
ist jedoch falsch. Aus Summen dürfen wir
nicht kürzen. Wenn wir kürzen dürften,
dann hieße das ja, egal was wir für x einsetzen,
es kommt immer die 3 raus. Und da reicht ein
einziges Beispiel. Wir setzen für x eine
Zahl ein, nehmen wir die 1, das sind 4. Also
4/1. Da kommt 4 raus für das Beispiel. Und
nicht 3! Und je nachdem was wir für x einsetzen.
Wir erhalten hier immer einen anderen Wert.
Das heißt (3+x)/x ist das gleiche. Wir dürfen
es nicht verändern. Wir haben jedoch die
Möglichkeit beide Summanden durch x zu dividieren.
Dann ergibt sich 3/x + x/x. Wir erhalten zwei
Brüche. Und dann können wir x/x kürzen
zu 1 und haben dann stehen 3/x + 1. Eine korrekte
Umformung. Ihr könnt ja die Probe machen.
Wir hatten ja hier die 1 eingesetzt, da kam
4 raus. Setzen wir hier für x die 1 ein:
3/1 + 1 sind auch 4. Wunderbar.
Fehler Nummer 4:
Die Potenzgesetze! Einige die das hier auflösen
schreiben dahin ist gleich -x². Und das ist
natürlich falsch. Dieses Minus steht ja nicht
vor der Klammer, sondern in der Klammer und
durch das Quadrat müssen wir den Inhalt der
Klammer mit sich selbst multiplizieren. Schreiben
wir das hier mal aus. Das bedeutet also (-x)*(-x).
Und das Minus mal Minus ist Plus und x*x ist
x². Das heißt hier kommt x² raus und nicht
-x². Auch müsst ihr aufpassen, wenn ihr
nur ein -x² stehen habt und dann für x einen
Wert einsetzt. Zum Beispiel die 3. Dann schreiben
hier einige als Ergebnis 9 hin. Was jedoch
falsch ist! Die Potenz muss zuerst berechnet
werden, also 3² und dann wird das Minus davor
gestellt. Denkt euch einfach eine Klammer
um 3². Und erinnert euch: Punktrechnung geht
vor Strichrechnung. Wenn wir die 3² ausschreiben,
haben wir -3*3 und wir erkennen als Ergebnis
-9.
Fehler Nummer 5:
Wenn hier ein 5x steht, dann wissen viele
nicht, dass das 5*x bedeutet. Und dann wird
der folgende Fehler gemacht. Stellen wir uns
vor wir hätten hier eine Gleichung 5x = y
und wir sollen jetzt für x den folgenden
Term einsetzen: x gleich y+2. Dann setzen
viele Schüler den Term direkt so ein. Statt
x schreiben sie dann y+2. Und das ist nicht
korrekt. Wenn wir was für x einsetzen muss
das immer in Klammern stehen. Also dieser
gesamte Term ist x, das heißt wir müssen
die Klammer davor und dahinter setzen. Jetzt
ist es richtig und jetzt können wir mit dem
Distributivgesetz ausmultiplizieren: 5y+5*2,
also 10. In weiterer beliebter Fehler in dieser
Kategorie: Wenn wir ein negatives x haben
und für x eine negative Zahl einsetzen wie
zum Beispiel die -6, dann schreiben welche
einfach hin, ist gleich -6, was jedoch falsch
ist, denn wir haben ja -x stehen und jetzt
müssen wir für dieses x die -6 einsetzen.
Setzen eine Klammer, setzen die -6 ein und
wir sehen hier ist Minus Minus, was wiederum
6 ist. Also wir erhalten eine positive 6.
Okay, weiter zum nächsten Fehler.
Fehler Nummer 6:
Wenn wir eine solche schöne Klammer haben
mit einem Minus davor, schreiben einige, wenn
sie die Klammer auflösen einfach -x+y, was
jedoch falsch ist, denn nicht nur x wird negativ,
sondern auch y wird negativ. Damit ihr hier
zukünftig keine Fehler macht, ein kleiner
Tipp. Schreibt das Minus vor der Klammer als
-1, denn dann sieht man hier sehr schön das
Distributivgesetz. Wir müssen diese -1 multiplizieren
mit dem x und wir müssen sie multiplizieren
mit dem y. Und dann ist es ganz einfach zu
erkennen. -x+(-y). Und hier Plus und Minus
ergibt natürlich Minus. So haben wir dann
-x-y.
Fehler Nummer 7:
Division durch 0. 1:0 bzw. 1/0. Da haben einige
Schüler Ergebnisse raus wie zum Beispiel
1 oder 0. Aber bitte merken. Division durch
0 ist nicht definiert! Es gibt keinen Wert
der hier rauskommt. Also hier schreibt man
einfach „n. d.“ - nicht definiert. Die
Multiplikation mit 0 ist jedoch definiert
als 0. Also immer wenn ihr eine Zahl oder
einen Term mit 0 multipliziert kommt 0 raus.
Fehler Nummer 8:
Wenn jemand fragt: „Nenn mir eine Zahl größer
als -10“, dann sagen einige Schüler, als
Beispiel, „-100“, was leider falsch ist,
denn die Zahl -100 ist kleiner als -10. x
soll größer sein als -10 und dann ist x
beispielsweise -9, -8, 0 oder ein positiver
Wert. Und wenn ihr eine Zahl kleiner als -10
nennen sollt: x < -10, dann kann hier -11,-12
usw. eingesetzt werden. Gut.
Fehler Nummer 9:
Das ist ein Formulierungsfehler. Viele sagen
„Ich habe eine Problem bei dieser Gleichung:
5*x+x“. Das ist eine falsche Formulierung,
denn hier ist kein Gleichheitszeichen. Das
ist keine Gleichung! Hier müsste es richtig
heißen: „Ich habe ein Problem bei diesem
Term“, denn das ohne Gleichheitszeichen
ist nichts weiter als ein Term. Also ein „mathematisch
sinnvoller Ausdruck“. Eine Gleichung wäre,
wie der Name schon sagt etwas wo ein Gleichheitszeichen
dabei ist. Also eine Aussage getroffen wird.
5*x+x soll 10 sein, ist gleich 10. Also das
ist eine Gleichung. Das ist ein Term. Eine
Gleichung besteht aus einem Linksterm und
einem Rechtsterm und einem Gleichheitszeichen.
Auch beliebt sind übrigens Schreibfehler,
den es gibt welche, die Schreiben „Das ist
ein Therm“ so. Mehrzahl Therme. Aber diese
Therme mit h geschrieben ist ein öffentliches
Bad. Also bitte Terme ohne h schreiben! Oder
ein zweites Beispiel „reelle Zahlen“.
Das wird immer mit Doppel l geschrieben und
Doppel e. Manche schreiben das nämlich so
„reele Zahlen“ und manche schreiben „reale
Zahlen“. Richtig ist aber „reelle Zahlen“.
Fehler Nummer 10:
Wenn ihr diese Gleichung lösen sollt, müsst
ihr ja die Wurzel ziehen. Und einige Schüler
schreiben dann hin: x ist Wurzel(9) und x
ist gleich 3. Das ist jedoch nur ein Teil
der Lösung, denn wir wissen dass (-3)² ebenfalls
9 ist. Hier muss man also auch den negativen
Wert beachten. Das heißt wenn wir hier die
Wurzel ziehen schreiben wir ein Plusminus
vor die Wurzel und dann haben wir hier ein
Plusminus und hier ein Plusminus. Durch das
Plusminus erhalten wir zwei Ergebnisse, wir
müssen also den Index 1,2 heransetzen. Und
wir können ausschreiben: x_1 ist 3 und x_2
ist -3. Fertig! Zusätzlich sei erwähnt:
Die Wurzel aus einem negativen Wert ist für
die reellen Zahlen nicht definiert. Sobald
der Radikand also kleiner als 0 ist, erhalten
wir keine Lösung. Und noch ein Hinweis zu
den Wurzeln. Habt ihr so etwas wie Wurzel(x+y)
ist das nicht Wurzel(x) + Wurzel(y). Dieser
Term und dieser Term sind nicht gleich, die
sind ungleich, sofern x und y größer 0 sind.
Sehr schön. Das waren die 10 häufigsten
Fehler, die euch in Mathearbeiten Punkte kosten.
Wir hoffen diese Fehler werden euch nicht
mehr passieren. Schaut euch weitere Videos
von uns an, damit ihr besser in Mathe werdet.
Das war Echt Einfach TV. Wir machen gute Mathe-Videos
für euch!